le groupe Bernard rayotte est implanté
sur plusieurs secteurs dont mon
territoire donc de l'automobile à la
grande distribution et récemment le
groupe a racheté notre seul distillerie
situé à Saint-Laurent du Maroni
j'aimerais connaître le pourcentage de
Guyane est embauchée par le groupe dans
les différents secteurs en Guyane merci
pour être tout à fait clair une très
grande majorité de nos collaborateurs
sont recrutés localement et pour
différentes raisons la première donc il
y a une question d'attractivité du
territoire et la Guyane et je le
regrette mais la Guyane est un
territoire aujourd'hui qui a qui a du
mal à tirer donc dans une perspective de
retour pays j'imagine que là aussi c'est
pas nécessairement le territoire sur
lequel on a le plus de succès c'est un
premier point deuxième point enfin il
faut se dire les choses de manière
extrêmement pragmatique faire venir un
candidat de l'extérieur c'est quelque
chose qui coûte cher ça coûte cher à
l'entreprise ça coûte cher aux candidats
et c'est une vraie prise de risque à la
fois pour le candidat et à la fois pour
l'entreprise donc dans toute la mesure
du possible l'entreprise et croyez-moi
je passais ça fait partie mes
discussions quotidiennes avec avec la
famille Ayotte on doit privilégier
autant que faire ce peu le recrutement
local et c'est le cas c'est vraiment le
cas en Guyane on doit également
s'assurer de développer des compétences
locales ce qu'on fait j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure une initiative en Guyane
vis-à-vis de jeunes qui sont plutôt
éloignés de l'emploi ce qu'on fait
également pour la partie anti sur la
distribution où on a des formations on a
mis en œuvre des formations qu'on a fait
venir de métropole pour le coup parce
qu'elles sont particulièrement reconnues
et qui nous permettent aujourd'hui de
former nos chefs de rayon on recrute
maintenant localement tous les ans 40 à
50 chefs de rayon qui sont les premiers
niveaux d'encadrement dans la grande
distribution qui permet de grande
carrière donc c'est vraiment nous
assurer qu'on recrute localement nos
cadres dans la grande distribution pour
nous donner que que cet exemple